We can get this expression
by using our formula, where we substitute the
all-zero string for x and substitute x for y,
noting that the binary dot
product of the all-zero string with any string is 0.
But we can also just reason this directly. We're taking the tensor
product of n plus states, and this is what we get,
tensor to the minus state. Then the UF gate is applied, and here's where the phase
kickback phenomenon happens.
The value f of x is getting
XORed onto the minus state for each x in the sum.
So f of x gets kicked into the phase.
We now apply another
layer of Hadamard gates just to the top n qubits, and this time, we really
do need the formula.
And when we apply it and do just a little
bit of simplification, we get this state right here.
So that's our final state just
prior to the measurements.
The state looks a little bit complicated, and it's difficult to simplify it because we don't really know
anything about the function f.
But remember, that all
we really need to know is whether or not the measurements
all yield the outcome 0,
because that's what determines what our answer is to the problem.
If we see that every
measurement outcome is 0, we conclude that the function is constant.
And if any one of the
measurement outcomes is 1, we conclude that the function is balanced.
So let's calculate the probability to get the all-zero string
from the measurements.
And that turns out to be the one result that's actually easy to calculate, because the binary dot
product of the all-zero string
with any string is zero. If we examine our vector and
we think about what happens when y is the all-zero string,
we get this expression right
here for the probability to get the all-zero string
from the measurements.
And considering the two possible cases where f is constant and f is balanced, we see that the probability to
get the all-zero string is 1
in the case that f is constant, and zero when f is balanced.
When f is constant, the sum is either 2 to the
n or negative 2 to the n, and dividing by two to the n
and taking the absolute
value squared yields 1.
And when f is balanced, the sum equals 0.
That's because we'll get
positive 1 and negative 1 an equal number of times,
so they all cancel out.
So that's it. The Deutsch-Jozsa algorithm
solves the Deutsch-Jozsa problem using a single query,
and there's no error. Assuming the operations
are all done perfectly, it's correct every single time.
So how does that compare with
what we can do classically?
Well, if we insist on a
deterministic algorithm that gets the answer
correct every single time, then in the worst case,
we need 2 to the n minus 1 plus 1 queries, and that's because we
have to query the function
on more than half of its inputs to be sure about the solution.
Even if we query the function on 2 to the n minus 1
different input strings, it's possible that we'll
see the same output value
every single time, and that could be because
the function is constant, or it could be that it's actually balanced
and we've just been incredibly unlucky having seen the same output
value every single time.
So that's a huge advantage
of quantum over classical, a single query versus
exponentially many queries.
However, if we use a
probabilistic query algorithm and we accept a small probability that it answers incorrectly,
then we actually only need a few queries.
In particular, if we
randomly choose k strings and evaluate the function
on those random strings,
then we are pretty likely to be able to figure out the right answer.
Specifically, we answer 0 or constant when we get the same function
value every single time and 1 or balanced
whenever we see two
different function values.
If we do that, we'll always be correct when
the function is constant because, of course, we'll always see the same
output value in this case.
And if f is balanced, we're very likely to see
two different output values.
The chance that we don't see
both output values in this case is the same as the chance that we have of flipping a coin k times
and getting the same
result every single time.
So for example, if we
set k to be equal to 11, the probability of getting a wrong answer is less than a 10th of a percent.
So especially when we consider the fact that quantum computers are never going to be perfect in reality, we don't actually get that
big of an advantage here,
but we're making progress, and we do have a quantifiable advantage of quantum over classical that goes beyond Deutsch's algorithm.
We can also use the Deutsch-Jozsa circuit to solve a different query problem known as the Bernstein-Vazirani problem.
Here's a statement of that problem. The input is a function
from n bits to 1 bit, just like the Deutsch-Jozsa problem,